[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs mes chers amis je
suis très ému de me retrouver avec vous
en cette soirée du 19 octobre 2040 pour
fêter ensemble et pour vous remettre le
prix des futurs souhaitables pour fêter
les réussites du projet de territoire
vision 2040 guadeloupe championne du
vivant merci aux organisateurs d'avoir
organisé une soirée avec un thème 2020
et je suis vraiment très touché de voir
à quel point vous avez tous fait un
effort vous êtes sauvent in touch même
l'équipement c'est normal que ça montre
un petit peu de défaillance date de 2020
donc bravo vraiment bravo
aujourd'hui la gauche la guadeloupe est
devenu un exemple inspirant d'économie
régénératrice réconciliant enjeux
climatiques de protection de la nature
est en jeu humaniste l'île célèbre ses
diversités les conjuguent pour créer une
dynamique de résilience et de solidarité
aujourd'hui vos citoyens et citoyennes
sont des experts reconnus dans la zone
caraïbes et partout dans le monde
ils forment au changement de trajectoire
vers des économies
re génératrices et qui donne envie de se
lever chaque matin pour atteindre des
objectifs atteignables et apporter sa
contribution aussi modeste soit elle à
cette grande aventure humaine mais cela
n'a pas été simple loin s'en faut
en 2020 rappelez-vous beaucoup perdre
espoir de grandes puissances semblait
vouloir se replier sur elle même dans
une vision égoïste et protectionniste ni
en la nécessité d'un changement radical
et rapide de nos modes de production et
de consommation et de notre inscription
au monde
je vois d'ailleurs que certains d'entre
vous sont assez ému ce soir suite à la
nouvelle que nous avons reçu ce matin du
décès du prix nobel de la paix 2032
monsieur donald trump
c'est incroyable de penser au parcours
de cet homme qui lorsqu'il était
président des états unis
mépriser les diversités et les réponses
collectives que nous tentions d'apporter
aux grands enjeux du moment
quels changements quand même c'est
incroyable quel virage total il a su
faire quelques années plus tard pour
l'économie en général trice et solidaire
mais en 2020 beaucoup ne comprenait pas
que si nous mettions félix éboué et
maryse condé avec mère teresa dalaï lama
d'ailleurs aussi autour d'un jeu de
monopoly la fin et sera toujours la même
il y aura un gagnant et des perdants
il ne s'agissait pas tellement juste
d'une question de joueurs mais également
du design du jeu lui-même en 2020 nous
avions peur peur des fins de mois
difficiles peur des impacts de nos
déchets de nos pollutions peur même de
boire l'eau de nos collectivités peur
des ouragans peur de l'augmentation du
niveau de la mer peur de nos marées
d'algues sargasses peur de nos frères et
soeurs en humanité migrants peur de nos
diversités dans les années 20 nous
étions plusieurs à réaliser que les
solutions du xxème siècle était
peut-être devenus les problèmes du 21e
mais je me rappelle aussi qu'un jour de
nathalie en guadeloupe avait dit
j'aimerais bien revoir les papillons de
mon enfance il y en avait tellement il y
en a tellement moins maintenant à cause
des pesticides mais en 2020 vous ne
faisiez pas seulement attention aux
arbres qui tombent beaucoup en
guadeloupe et ailleurs préféré repérer
et stimuler les jeunes pousses qui
essayait de pousser au milieu du fracas
ces innovations ses porteurs de projets
pleins de sens qui ne donnait à voir à
l'époque ce que demain pouvait être à
l'aune de ce qu'il y à 2
hier pascal nicolas sylvifrancs qui vont
jean marie christelle et vous autres
vous vous souvenez en 2020 pardon 2019
je crois de tedx pointe à pitre intitulé
c'est déjà demain
je crois que c'était ça non c'est déjà
demain ou c'est peut-être demain c'est
déjà demain
vous vous souvenez d enthousiasme que ça
avait généré mais aussi des doutes
beaucoup disaient c'est génial mais ici
c'est pas possible
nous avons trop d'inertie trop de
problèmes à composer avec nos diversités
trop de bureaucratie
mais certains ont su dire c est qu ils h
et l'impossible n'est que temporaire ici
c'est le pays des rebelles
accueillant il n'y a pas que dans le
sport que nous pouvons être des
champions mais avant que vous puissiez
donner de la lumière du terreau et de
l'eau comme le recommander ils vont à
ces jeunes pousses guadeloupéen
prometteuse il a fallu malheureusement
que quelques grands fracas nous ouvre
encore les yeux un peu plus et le coeur
vous savez bien que je fais référence
ici à cette très dures années 2024 avec
ces successions de crises financières de
superbes ragan le crise sociale et
sanitaire qui ont frappé les antilles
mais aussi le monde
ce fut dur très dur cette année là nous
a cruellement rappelé à tous notre
fragilité
mais cette crise de 2024 a aussi été le
début d'un vrai changement de cap après
2024 pour vous tous il n'était plus
devenu acceptable que plus de 80 % de
l'alimentation de la guadeloupe ne soit
pas produite sur place
après 2024 il n'était plus admissible
pour vous que les citoyens de l'île
aient peur de boire leur eau par crainte
des pollutions comme celle du
chlordécone
il n'était plus tenable de consommer en
guadeloupe plus de 150 millions de
bouteilles en plastique par an après
2024 vous n'avez plus accepter que
l'immense majorité de l'énergie de l'île
plus de 75 % dépendent d'hydrocarbures
venant en plus de l'extérieur
fin 2000 24 une assemblée tirés au sort
de 150 citoyens et citoyennes de la
guadeloupe a travaillé main dans la main
avec les élus et l'état pour essayer de
réfléchir ensemble à une vision pour un
développement souhaitable de la
guadeloupe à l'horizon 2040
dans une première phase qui a duré un an
des milliers d'experts sont venus pas
des milliers quand même et les meilleurs
sont venus vous former et vous informer
ce collectif qui venait d'ailleurs pas
simplement de guadeloupe mais du reste
du monde
ils sont venus vous présenter les
meilleures solutions les meilleures
grille de lecture on a découvert qu'il
était possible de la voir de l'eau
propre en extrayant de l'air on a
découvert pendant des formations des
outils comme l' approche stratégique du
développement durable le biomimétisme
l'art de s'inspirer 3,8 milliards
d'années de recherche et développement
la permaculture l'économie circulaire
l'économie sociale et solidaire
l'économie régénératrice et symbiotique
de nouvelles grilles de lecture de la
complexité des enjeux vous ont été
proposées et vous les avez challenge et
enfin 2025
ce collectif a enfin présenté vision
2040 guadeloupe championne du vivant et
nous sommes ensemble aujourd'hui quinze
ans plus tard pour célébrer vos
réalisations
aujourd'hui la guadeloupe est considérée
comme quasiment autonome sur le plan
alimentaire et énergétique
le plan sont gaye caribéen a permis que
80 % de l'alimentation soit à présent
produite sur l'île
les 20% restants étant des aliments non
essentiels de confort
souvenez-vous en 2020 quelques projets
novateurs comme la culture en pot
d'arbres fruitiers du projet
rêvons ont commencé à polliniser par les
aspects positifs que ça généré y compris
au niveau social toute l'île en
initiatives similaires des particuliers
des entreprises des collectivités se
sont mises à cultiver en pot sans
employer aucun pestis
si dans un petit bourg les collégiens du
collège félix éboué ont créé un
partenariat en 2020 avec aqua pony
antilles pour développer dans leur
collège un exemple d'agroécologie en
circuits courts et en circuit fermé
en bouclant les flux de matière et
d'énergie cela a inspiré leurs parents
et certains collégiens quelques années
plus tard ont lancé des projets
entrepreneuriaux similaire dans ses
projets les productions végétales et
animales sont associés les déchets de
l'ain devenant les ressources de l'autre
les vers de terre permettent le
compostage
ils servent d'alimentations poulet qui
eux-mêmes permettre de produire des
poissons en aqua pony l'eau enrichi en
déchets est utilisé pour faire des
productions maraîchères et tout ça a
créé un développement également des
réseaux locaux d'associations pour le
maintien d'une agriculture paysanne les
amap comme il existait un exemple qui
datait d'ailleurs de 2010 gwada map à
morne-à-l'eau ça permet de tisser des
liens sociaux de créer des emplois en
d'avoir bien sûr avant tout une
nourriture saine et aussi de garantir
aux producteurs un revenu stable et
équitable des coopératives d'épicerie
citoyenne permettent de proposer à
partir de 2020 2021 des bas prix des
produits sains et le coup en 2026
d'importants investissements en
permaculture marine ont permis de créer
le premier éco parts de fermes aquacoles
prêt à faire collaborer ensemble des
production d'algues des productions de
poissons dans des enclos qui essaye
d'imiter les écosystèmes marins et en
plus de ça certains enclos capable de
résister en haute mer à des événements
climatiques extrêmes ont été conçus ici
en guadeloupe et exporté à travers le
monde
en ce qui concerne les énergies
renouvelables et la lutte contre le
bouleversement climatique
grâce aux plans zen zéro émissions
nettes la relocalisation de la
production d'énergies décarbonées près
des lieux de consommation a pu avoir
lieu
c'était possible grâce à un bouquet de
solutions
rappelez-vous en 2020 l'initiative plus
belles larry permettait à ses habitants
d'embellir le quartier de carénage en
l'initiative s'est généralisée à
l'ensemble des zones urbaines et à créer
une nouvelle dynamique qui a conduit à
des réflexions à l'échelle des quartiers
ça s'est élargi y compris aux aspects
énergétiques et alimentaires
un nouveau concept de bâtiment
bioclimatique est également menée en
guadeloupe en dès 2022
couplant performance énergétique
matériaux sains et respectueux de
l'environnement et adaptation aux
événements climatiques extrêmes
grâce à ces éco conception la demande
énergétique s'est stabilisé autour de
300 mille mégawatts et lille est
autonome en énergie
depuis 2000 32 ans géothermie les deux
centrales de bouillante ont augmenté
leurs capacités et cette source
d'énergie compter en 2032 pour à peu
près 30% des besoins énergétiques de
lille en ce qui concerne l'éolien
grâce à un partenariat avec l'entreprise
will power systems qui s'est inspiré en
fait des nageoires des baleines à bosse
qui ont des petites bosses qui facilite
l'écoulement des fluides
ça a permis de créer des éoliennes
rétractable fonctionnant mieux à faible
et grand vent elles ont été déployés et
couplé à des processus de stockage de
l'énergie par hydrogène mais également
de pompage de l'eau dans des bassins
quand le relief le permettaient qui
permettait en fait de en situation de
faible vent d'utiliser l'énergie
hydrolienne
en ce qui concerne les déchets et les
pollutions le plan guadeloupe zéro
déchet initiants 2025 a pu permettre de
dire mission accomplie en sept ans
seulement
comme dans la nature ou une feuille
morte devient une ressource pour
d'autres organismes
cette économie circulaire qui a vu les
volumes de déchets de l'île diminué de
72 % en 2032 et tous les autres déchets
sont valorisés plus tôt c'est devenu des
coproduits les sargasses et la bagasse
sont récoltés pour fabriquer des
matériaux de construction pour les
maisons bioclimatiques mais aussi pour
des objets du quotidien comme des
gourdes qui remplace le plastique et
puis surtout on a utilisé ses déchets
agricoles et des sargasses pour extraire
des principes actifs
très intéressant pour la chimie verte en
est utilisé par la cosmétique et le
biomédical résultats en 2040
les antilles sont un des plus grands
lieux d'enseignement et de recherche en
termes de valorisation de ses co
produits agricoles 525 plantes
médicinales 220 espèces comestibles ont
été identifiés et en 2038
il y à peine deux ans l'objectif zen a
été atteint la guadeloupe est à présent
une île zéro émissions nettes par la
régénération des milieux naturels
dégradés par le développement de
symbiose industrielle initiée dès 2020
par l'association l'effet papillon le
développement d'habitat bioclimatique
particulièrement low-tech est à base de
matériaux construit avec la bagasse et
la sargasse par la valorisation des
déchets ou plutôt des coproduits
agricoles l'économie de la guadeloupe
considèrent à présent comme atteignable
d'être la première économie insulaire au
monde
globalement fixatrice de carbone comme
tout le reste du vivant sur cette
planète
et comme le disait justement vous pouvez
vous applaudir pour ça
comme le disait juste avant que je ne
rentre en scène julia dit surtout hors
de guadeloupe que si nous sommes
capables de le faire sur notre île petit
monde
nous montrons au vaste monde que nous
sommes capables de le faire pour notre
planète
je suis très ému merci pour votre
contribution au changement de
trajectoire du monde vers des futurs
souhaitables
vous avez montré que l'impossible
n'était que temporaire qu'il est
toujours toujours important de prendre
new rave au sérieux et d'en faire une
stratégie et vous savez quoi
les papillons sont revenus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]